each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so I would introduce Jeremy but
apparently this is already a sort of
reunion but for those of you who don't
know Jeremy Conda he's graduating from
UC Berkeley soon he'll be telling us
about a language that he's written
called deputy and the systems that
benefit from this all right thank you
very much it's a pleasure to be back
here I guess I'm sort of a I was sort of
a serial Microsoft intern i was here
twice as an undergrad and twice more the
graduate student and so coming back to
seattle it feels like coming home so i
shall i shall all right so today I'm
going to talk about deputy which is a
system that I built that uses dependent
types to enforce safety and system
software and maybe my clicker will work
there we go okay so first of all quote
from Dykstra programming has become one
of our most demanding intellectual
activities requiring great clarity
expression and the utmost economy of
reasoning presumably if you're building
a big system you take this philosophy to
heart but a lot of cases it doesn't
quite work out this way systems are
built in a very ad hoc manner and
they're very difficult to reason about
so how are we build systems that
actually work the problem is systems
have become so huge that a single person
can't understand even the small portion
of it much less how the whole thing fits
together and how the whole thing works
my approach is to use programming
language techniques to help us solve
these the problems of big systems using
program language techniques we can
actually reason formally and
mechanically about lower-level portions
of code allowing the programmer to think
at a more at a higher level about how
the code works so in general if you look
at these two research areas software
systems tends to tends to reason about
how you build larger and larger systems
on how you and and how you understand
the interactions among them and
languages loves allows you to have this
or a formal and mechanical reasoning
about code so the risk of being perhaps
a little too general you could say that
software systems rely on abstractions in
order to build bigger and better systems
and
languages help us enforce those
abstractions so in my research so far
there have been two main projects that
use this approach one is a project
called capriccio which talked about how
you use whether you use threads or
events to build big servers like like a
web server and capriccio showed that
there was this duality between threads
and events where threads and events are
actually these these two approaches to
programming actually produce very
similar code and so really it just comes
down to which the which model the
programmer prefers and in many cases the
thread model tends to be attends to work
well so capriccio use this language
tools of techniques in order to get the
same scalability and performance out of
a threads package that we'd previously
seen from event systems today I'm going
to focus on a newer project which is
deputy and this allows us to enforce
type safety and memory safety in
existing C programs so deputies sort of
the language side of this and then we've
used it to build a tool called safe
drive which helps enforce safety within
a between the a Linux driver and the
lives colonel so in this talk I'm going
to first give you an overview of deputy
and safe drive themselves we'll talk
about the motivation for the work we'll
talk about we'll talk about a little bit
about how deputy works and it has that's
been used within safe drive itself then
i'll talk about in detail about how
deputy works and then and then safe
drive itself finally some related in
future work so how do we motivate this
this work so first of all there's
millions of lines of c code out there in
fact probably probably in the billions
of lines of code out there certainly
millions that are safety critical and
there's a huge investment in in building
up this code from from nothing you know
over the over the past few decades
there's been a lot of programmer effort
that goes into making code that that is
that performs well that is that is well
tested that works as the user as the
users want and it's hard to
underestimate the value of this existing
code the problem is this most of these
systems are written in C and this is
sort of inherently unsafe and unreliable
it doesn't give us and it doesn't give
us the sort of high-level safety
properties that we'd like to get out of
a out of a more modern programming
language so what we'd like to do is have
some sort of incremental transition we'd
like to take all of this
dis ting code that we haven't see and
incrementally move it onto a on to a
more solid foundation so this is sort of
this is sort of the high-level
motivation for the work we're doing in
particular we're going to look at type
in memory safety and that's and those
are the things that the deputy itself
enforces so type safety says the runtime
values for for a variable or a location
in memory correspond to their
compile-time type so an example error
here maybe we have a variable with type
manager and a variable type in turn now
and see you're allowed to cast the
manager to an intern and it just
believes you it says okay this manager
is now an intern and then you can you
can ask the intern to fetch coffee
except you're actually asking your
manager to fetch coffee so this this is
a case where so this is a case where
where if you look at the third line
alone you'd like to be able to believe
those types but in C because C allows
you to do these arbitrary type casts you
can't actually you can't actually take
the compilers word for it this type
actually has the appropriate value at
runtime we're also interested in memory
safety which says that which says that
all accesses are within bounds so if you
have an array of length 42 you want to
be able to to know that if you try to
access the 100 element that array that
you'll get some sort of you'll get some
sort of error see doesn't enforce these
properties but in fact most programmers
do enforce these properties when they
actually write code so we can do a
little better we can actually take C
programs and try to enforce these
properties in in these existing C
programs why is this so important so
first of all its security critical back
in nineteen nineteen eighty-eight Robert
Morris's internet worm took down a huge
swath of the internet due to a buffer
overflow bug in the finger D program and
more recently even in the early 2000s
we've had programs or viruses like Code
Red and sequel slammer that have used
buffer overflows in in some important
products that many of us use in order to
in order to once again take down you
know a large number of computers cost
billions of dollars of damage so this is
a this is a pretty important problem and
lets you believe that this has already
been fixed there have actually been a
number of recently exploitable bugs so
I got this just with a five minute
search for buffer overflows on the cert
website Internet Explorer there was a
buffer overflow in the handling for vml
in in September QuickTime and Java
Runtime both had buffer overflow bugs
that were remotely exploitable in
January and all of these you just had to
direct your web browser at some page
that served malicious content and and
your machine is under somebody else's
control its particular noteworthy that
the this third case the Java Runtime job
is supposed to be a a safe language it's
supposed to have all these security
properties would like to enforce but
it's built upon see it's implemented in
C and so all of the all of the dangerous
parts of see that that plague us sort of
propagate up two languages that are
built on top of it the second of all
this type of memory safety helps us
isolate parts of the system so and we'll
see this a little bit later we can we
can isolate say an operating system
kernel from defects in the drivers
themselves and there's this widely
quoted number that were something like
eighty five percent of windows of
windows crashes are caused by bugs and
the drivers themselves because the
drivers are less tested and written by
non-experts so if we can isolate errors
if we can isolate the kernel itself from
errors and the drivers that's a pretty
big win finally type in memory safety
are a foundation for many other analyses
we'd like to do so pretty much any other
analysis you perform on on C code starts
out by saying let's assume type in
memory safety and work from there so
this so this work sort of lays the
foundation for for many future analyses
so what does deputy do deputy and this
is this is sort of the slide to pay
attention to so if you fall asleep for
the rest of the talk you know here's
this is where the important stuff is
deputy enforces type in memory safety
and C code it's designed to work in
existing programs and to scale up to to
actual real programs like the Linux
kernel and you know hopefully you can
use it on say windows itself it uses
dependent types to enable a modular
approach so the idea is we're going to
use we're going to talk about we're
going to allow the program to talk about
dependencies in the interfaces between
the between different portions of the
program which allow you to use deputy
just on a single portion of the program
then gradually expand it to the rest of
the program as as you have time and
we'll take a case study which is a safe
drive where we've used this for Linux
drivers that are talking to the
unmodified linux kernel so from the pl
view the interesting the interesting
part of this work is that we have
dependent types for real-world programs
also dependent types have been studied
pretty widely over for a couple decades
but here's an example of actually taking
them and using them in real code from
the system points from the systems point
of view we have this modular fine grain
type safety that's enforced because
because we use a language tool and will
and will show how this is this is
actually used in safe drive in order to
in order to get modular safety all right
so here's a here's a quick overview of
what what deputy o does and how it works
so imagine we have a structure called
buffer that has two fields it called
data in line so looking at this is the
programmer you probably say okay well
data points to a array of length of
length lent and the programmer is you
know put these two fields here for a
reason but if you're the compiler all
you see is a pointer in an integer and
you don't really know that there's any
association here so say we'd like to
check that that there's access to be
data I at the bottom of the screen is
correct now if you're as the programmer
you probably look through through here
and say oh well we're looping from zero
to beat Len and we're accessing that
element I'm so it's probably safe what
previous approaches did was because they
didn't they didn't understand the
correlation between these two fields was
they inserted extra data so this is
secured which I worked on at Berkeley
and cyclone which came out of Cornell
and AT&T both took this approach
basically instead of just having this
data field they would add two extra
fields base an end in order to hold the
base and end of the region into which
this into which this pointer point and
based on that you can insert a check you
could make sure that that the address
they were accessing be dot data plus I
is between the base in the end the
problem here is that we now change the
layout of data structures so this data
structure used to have just two fields
and now it has four which makes it
incompatible with other code that's real
it relies on this on this layout so the
problem here is that you had to
essentially apply these tools to the
entire program or to nothing at all and
inevitably even if you run
on the whole program at once it still
wants to talk to something to some
library that you don't have the access
to the can't recompile and basically
ends up being a big nightmare deputies
approach is to use a dependent type so
this is a type annotation that says that
the pointer this pointer called data is
actually a pointer to a buffer of length
Lin where land is the other is the other
field in the structure so now we can
insert an assertion that just says that
I is between 0 and b ln so there are a
number of advantages here first of all
there's been no change in the data
structure because we've just inserted a
type annotation as opposed to changing
the layout of the data structure this
this code can still be linked with code
that's not compiled by deputy second
this code is easier to optimize so
you'll see that the check we've inserted
checks that I is between 0 and b ln but
the programmer has actually already
checked this they've checked that eyes
that I is less than B dot Len because
we're in this case we're actually using
their metadata so here a good optimizer
could come along and determine that I no
longer need to check that I is less than
B dot Len and in fact you could
eliminate this entire assertion finally
there's it's beneficial just from a
program maintenance point of view
because the contract is in the code the
programmer has written in this code that
that this that this pointer depends on
the value of this length which is a nice
thing to have around for future maintain
the code so the key inside here is that
most the information we need in order to
do bounds checking and in order to do
even more general type checking is
already in the program in some form but
just not in a form of compiler
understands and so deputy's dependent
types will allow you to label this
information and will allow the compiler
to perform checks based on it it's also
important to note that these annotations
will not be trusted in any way they'll
be used on one side of the interface to
perform checking and they'll be checked
than another side of the interface to
make sure that they're obeyed by the
rest of the code so we've got here as a
dependent type yep
before you said one of the adventure
said you can call code that is not how
the deputy right yeah but then of course
you're not going to get you sure yeah
you only get cured I guess if you cure
able to find on everything you will get
there on time checking right it's sort
of what we've found is that is that you
know there's sort of there's any units
of programmer work in order to apply
secure to a big program and you know
there's about any units of work to a
apply deputy to a similar-sized program
the advantages that you get to you get
to you get to apply that those units of
work and test them bit by bit as you as
you progress to the program so you can
apply deputy to a single single source
file link it against the rest of the
program run it see what you what you
broke fix it with see cured you have to
make all of this modifications then you
run the program something breaks you
have no idea so there's so the major
benefit is this incremental approach
because we're because we're just using
the programmers data uh we can make this
transition bit by bit you can also i
guess the versions were the metadata was
out of line you were actually able to
link your good stuff that it's not crap
islands right so the question i'm not
sure if i should be repeating questions
here for the yeah so the question was
whether you could with c cured store the
metadata elsewhere which is actually a
project that I worked on as my master's
thesis you could separate out you know
if you had a list of a list of objects
that had that had a secret metadata you
could separate that into a list of
objects of the original format and a
list of meditative objects the big
disadvantage there was that even though
you could separate out the data
structures and pass the only the data
portion to an external code the external
code was not aware that there was this
extra minute of it need to be maintained
yeah so they're out of sync if the other
guy makes changes to it you have to sync
them up somehow so really it's better
just to be able to say here's the data
it's already in the code and that even
that other code that you're passing this
to you even though it won't be checked
by deputy will hopefully be designed so
that it maintains these invariants
so this is so the right so the key
inside here is that the balance
information is already here and we can
use this to do checks so so we've got
here is a dependent type we've got we've
declared a dependency between these two
fields and the the big the big problem
with the pendant types is that now the
meaning of a type depends on the run
time value of some other part of the
program so in order to reason about
whether it's safe to have something in
data we have to we have to think about
what runtime values lend my take on and
i'm getting a call from somebody who
apparently objects this talk yeah all
right this is what you never want to
have happen huh anyway so dependent
types are types of being depends on
their the value of some other run of
some other portion of the program so the
big the big challenges here is that in
order to check these types we need to
know what values other part of the
program might take on so in order to
check whether whether data has this type
we need to know what values Len might
take on the other hand dependent types
enable these modular this modular
checking because we can declare that the
dependencies between these fields and
and we don't have to add any new
metadata okay so we get this module we
get its modular checking why is this
important we've already gone over this a
little bit in the process of these
questions but basically it's a it's an
alternative to whole program analysis if
a source codes unavailable or we can't
recompile it then we can then we can
apply this tool to just one portion of
the program and we also it also allows
this incremental approach so we can we
can improve the program module by module
and we can also improve the code quality
bit by bit because we can just we can
even mark trusted portions of the code
that will come back to later once we
once the tool improves or once we have
ones who have time to redesign the code
so how does this work in in an actual
system imagine we have a colonel with a
few drivers that plug into it the
problem here is that is that a bug in
the driver can bring down the entire
system it can essentially cause
corruption within the kernel itself this
is a pattern that shows up a lot so this
is a
kernel driver is an obvious example but
there's also you know web servers with
modules there's web browsers with
plugins this this pattern shows up all
over the place where you have sort of
untrusted and untested code plugging
into a much more trusted and tested
codebase a previous system solution is
the the nooks project from the
University of Washington which had an
isolation layer that surrounded a Linux
driver and protected it from protected
the the Linux kernel from errors in the
driver the problem here was the driver
can still corrupt itself so if you have
a file system driver for example it
could corrupt date on your file system
even though it wasn't bringing down the
entire kernel and second this isolation
layer is pretty complicated it's about
22,000 lines of code that has to do with
marshaling data through marshaling
Colonel objects that were previously
just passed directly between the kernel
and the driver now an alternative
approach is to use this language
approach that we talked about earlier
with something like C cure to cyclone
now here we enforce safety within the
within the driver itself so we rule out
these type and memory safety errors
within the driver and prevent them from
corrupting colonel but we still have to
change the interface in order to do this
and that means we needed this adapter
layer which is just as complicated as
the isolation layer we just got rid of
with deputy will be able to will be able
to enforce safety without changing the
interface and therefore have the driver
plugged directly into the kernel without
this without this fancy adapter or fancy
isolation layer all right oh so the cost
here is that we had to annotate this
interface so we need programmer effort
to go through and and indicate what the
relationships are between these
variables but as it turns out all of
these all of these solutions involve
some form of program or effort and we'd
like to have the programmers expending
this effort in a task that they
understand and sort of at their level of
reasoning as opposed to writing a sort
of one-off adapter or isolation layer
and of course we need the driver source
as well though this is something that we
could we could address with future work
if we could have a verifier that
verifies that the code has been properly
processed by by deputy or similar tool
okay so that's the high level view of
this work let's take a look at how
deputy itself works
as I've said before deputy relies on
dependent types to talk about
relationships between variables in the
programs and we can use and we can use
this to annotate common see idioms so
you know you have a buffer here and its
length over here previous dependent type
systems are sort of an appropriate for
this for this work because they expect
to do most of their checking statically
and these programs that were that were
that we're running this on our don't
really expect at were written weren't
written with the expectation that they
would that they would be checked by a
one of these static checkers so the big
challenges here either we'd like to
reason about runtime values at compile
time in order to check these dependent
types we want to handle mutation because
it's possible that C code will change a
value that somebody else depends upon
and finally we just want to make this
usable for real programmers so to see
the the high level view of how deputy
differs from previous dependent type
systems will look at static versus
hybrid checking so previous previous
dependent type systems took a static
approach deputy takes a hybrid approach
imagine that all programs could be put
somewhere on this spectrum between
correct programs and incorrect programs
on the far left we have the trivial us
like hello world and on the far right we
have trig early incorrect programs like
something that just crashes immediately
and obviously an operating system is
probably somewhere in the middle of it
in the middle of this and maybe on the
other side of this of this line so if
you had an ideal type checker maybe if
you had an ideal type checker yeah yeah
singularity is alway over that it's hey
hey on my screen it's to the left you
know anyway so if we had an ideal type
checker we'd be able to split these into
at compile time into two categories we
could accept all correct programs and
reject all incorrect programs but thanks
to the halting problem this is
impossible for any for any non-trivial
definition of correctness so if you have
a previous dependent type type system
what they did was they accepted a very
fraction of the correct programs and
rejected a lot of correct programs in
addition to the incorrect ones what
deputy is going to do so you know the
operating system that we're hoping to
make correct and some point in the
future sits somewhere in this in this
region programs we've rejected even
though they are hopefully correct so we
have no runtime checks but this is
unsuitable for existing code for deputy
we're going to take a different approach
we're going to accept the same small
fraction of programs reject the number
of incorrect programs and then in the
middle will accept a bunch of them with
runtime checks and then at runtime will
distinguish between the ones that are
where the check succeed and where the
checks fail and in this case the the
ones that we act we can actually accept
it at runtime are a much greater
fraction of the correct programs and so
hopefully our operating system will
eventually fall in this area yes lies
chicks may fail subtly so it actually
goes into the crow crows I guess that's
right there are some cases that we still
might not be able to that we still might
not be able to catch whether even with a
runtime check yeah yeah the checks
themselves might be too conservative I
know it's not going to be possible in 2d
but you should probably also have some
correct programs that you're going to
reject right you still some some correct
programs that we were to reject a
compile-time yes right yes so right so
the advantage here is that this is more
suitable for existing code because it's
conceivable that we can have an
operating system that could be accepted
using this technique but some errors
will get delayed and in fact some errors
might never get caught because if if
we're relying on runtime checks we have
to actually execute that code path in
order to find the error so to see why
this is useful consider this previous
example that we saw where we looped from
from 0 to be out Lin except now we're
looping from 0 to limit and this this
variable limit is derived by calling
some other function called get limit and
now in order to eliminate this check
statically we'd have to reason about the
relationship between bln which involves
knowing something about how get limit
works and so on so there could be some
higher level programmer and variant that
that the programmer knows about and the
programmer is reasoning about here but
we just can't take care of it compile
time so this is hard to prove statically
in deputy we can just leave this check
in at runtime and take care of it then
so a quick overview of how the compiler
works we're going to take a code with
some program or annotations that are
once again untrusted we're going to
infer some additional annotations so the
program doesn't have to do all the work
well go through an ad runtime checks and
then optimize those checks and will
produce a safe executable at the other
side so I'll show you a little bit about
how we insert those checks and why the
optimization is important so imagine
that we have a pointer that's labeled as
count n so this pointer has has n as a
pointer to a buffer of n elements and we
want to dereference it in this case if
the only check we need to perform is to
make sure that n is greater than zero
because if n is greater than zero
there's at least one element there to
dereference now if you're a PL
researcher you're used to writing out
rules like this so this is sort of the
standard rule for a c-type system which
says in this case that a variable P has
typed out star for some type town and if
you and so if this holds then this guy
must hold which says if you do reference
p it has type tab but of course we've
said nothing about whether it's actually
valid to dereference it at this point in
the program so what we'd like to do with
deputy is that a little bit of extra
information to this check here we say
here we we say that we now have this
count and annotation and we want to
check to make sure and is greater than 0
I've put the second premise in a box to
indicate that it might be checked at
runtime instead of a compile-time so
pretty much anytime you have one of
these rules that needs to say something
about a runtime value it'll be boxed in
the type checking role it's worth noting
that in the actual system we reason
about null pointers but I've emitted it
in this slide just for just for clarity
so for another example let's take
arithmetic we have a pointer P with the
same annotation and we want to add some
integer eat now here we want to check
that the new pointer is still within the
bounds of this of this array and the and
the new type of this pointer will be
sort of what we correspondingly smaller
because it's because it's further along
in the array the attack we want of
course is that E is between 0 and n so
this is the old rule we'd say that if we
have a pointer P with type tau star and
some integer then we can add the two and
get a new pointer of
same type but again it doesn't say
anything about whether this is whether
the bounds are obeyed so here we're
going to say if his original pointer has
count n and this integer is between 0
and n then we produce a new pointer
whose count is n minus e so once you've
run all these rules will we can sort of
accumulate all the runtime checks that
are associated with these boxes premises
the idea here is that because we've
deferred some these checks to run time
we have a hybrid type checker so now
let's take a combined example here we've
here we have this the same pointer P and
we're accessing element 5 which is a
arithmetic plaza dereference so if you
if you smash these rules together what
comes out is this the details are not
too important but what is important is
that you have we have a bunch of runtime
checks that are all somewhat redundant
here we've we've checked that zero is
less than or equal to 5 which is trivial
and we don't need to worry about we've
also checked that n is greater than
equal to 5 and the n is greater than 5
which is also redundant so the optimizer
has to come through and take care of
these checks it'll figure out which
these checks are are actually relevant
and get rid of the ones that aren't so
the final check the deputy will insert
will just check that n is greater than 5
which is the one you'd expect so the
overall strategy here is we have a
simple pass the code to generate these
checks and then a second pass with a
with a flow sensitive and much smarter
optimizer that can eliminate these
checks work where it's statically
possible so how do we deal with mutation
let's imagine that we have a dependency
on a variable that might itself get
changed so here I've introduced two new
annotations one is this Sentinel
annotation which just says yep yep
shorten the wraparound finitude how the
figurines is hmm you've eliminated less
than zero space so I potentially is a
dereference outside of the great mouse
so the way the checks are designed the
if a pointer has an as an unknown value
then it's then its bounds have already
been checked they've been derived from
some allocation so we already know that
those bounds represent so in fact the
bounds are stored not in terms of the
length but in terms of
pointers delimiting the upper and lower
bound of the pointer and those have
already been those have been sort of
derived and checked from some allocation
point so we know that those that the
lower bound is less than or equal to up
the upper bound and the checks for
arithmetic make sure the pointer never
strays out of that and checks to make
sure there's no overflow that could they
could give us the false impression that
this is still within bounds which is a
short way of saying that we check for
overflow and make sure that we won't get
those sort of ours yeah this these
checks are a little bit simplified so
for example in the real system we'd also
check to make sure PS not null ok so
here's here's the mutation example wait
and we've got two new annotations one is
the Sentinel annotation which just says
this pointer is for is is for bounds
purposes only and is not to be
dereferenced or moved itself we also
have a much more explicit bounds
annotation which is actually which is
actually what a more general case of
count which specifies explicitly the
base and end of the pointer of the
relevant pointer so here we said say
that data is bounded below by itself and
above by end now in a previous dependent
type system most most of these previous
systems said that you couldn't depend on
mutable data so it would simply be
illegal to to modify the value of
something that somebody else depended
upon here we have data which is which
appears in one of the dependencies but
it's actually legal to increment it
because if we increment data we still we
still we've preserved the type invariant
so data is still bounded below by data
and above by end we've just essentially
forgotten about this first element of
the array so we'd like to be able to to
accept these sorts of these sorts of
modifications were possible all right so
previous dependent type systems disallow
this assignment but deputy will use some
some reasoning from axiomatic semantics
in order to make this a little bit more
possible hmm so we're going to do is
we're going to view the art type
invariant as a as a predicate on the
state of the program we're going to say
we want to preserve this the invariant
these type hold at every point in the
program so here we have we have the
types of data and end we want to
preserve it across this assignment of
data plus one to data
now if we look at this in a little bit a
little bit more generality we could say
we have some invariant gamma at at the
beginning and we want to show the gamut
holds after after this assignment of
some expression e to some variable X
using axiomatic semantics we can compute
the weakest precondition of gamma across
X get c which is gamma with e
substituted for x throughout that
predicate so what really what we really
need to show now is that the original
gamma implies gamma with with e
substituted for x so this is so this is
sort of this is the main reason that we
need that we need to worry about in
order to in order to reason about
mutation in these programs to see how
this works out in our example let's
let's apply this week of weakest
precondition rule and so here we
substitute a data plus one for data
throughout this invariant and what we
need to show is that aren't variant
implies this week is precondition of
course it's easy to see that because end
has this type in start Sentinel it has
this type at the end as well the
interesting part is this case here but
you can you should be able to see that
starting with starting with a pointer
data that's bounded by data and end we
should be able to show that data plus
one is bounded by data plus one and end
and in fact type rules like the ones
that I've showed you earlier allow us to
derive this what they end up with is a
runtime check that makes sure the data
plus 1 is less than or equal to end
because we don't want data plus 1 to go
past the upper bound of the array so
this is the this shows how we can use
this week it's precondition logic in
order to in order to handle mutation in
some of these cases what really matters
here is is this reasoning on the Left
which says that gamma implies gamma with
e substitute for X it's important to
note here we haven't talked about any
specific dependent types we haven't
talked about bound or count or any of
the other types that were that we're
going to use and deputy so really this
this reasoning is very general we can
have a single rule that talks about how
to how to deal with mutation and
assignment independent of any of these
other types you want to add and this is
nice because we'd like to be able to
we'd like to be able to build a system
where we can add new dependent types to
express new idioms the programmer that
we find the programmer using
what are the restrictions here the main
restriction is that the dependency that
variables can only depend on other
variables in the immediately enclosing
scope so local variables can depend on
other locals we can have structure
fields depending on their structure
fields Global's and other Global's but
you can't have you can't depend sort of
across across pointer boundaries so for
example you can't you can't depend on
the on the run on the value get from
dereferencing a pointer and you can't
depend on the result of calling a
function because those are things that
this week is preconditioned logic
wouldn't be able to reason about
appropriately all right so we also need
to consider usability in addition to how
we add checked and how we deal with
mutation and inevitably this this boils
down to if some inference is required we
want to we want to have the programmer
adds some checks and then fill in the
rest we have three techniques automatic
dependencies pointer graph and some
basic assumptions we're just going to
focus on automatic dependencies for now
so the way this techniques work
technique works is we'd like to be able
to come up with a we would like people
to infer a new annotation for some local
variable so imagine we have a case where
we're here we have a function foo that
takes two variables P and Q both of
which are annotated with their length
peel n and q lot but we also have a
variable X that's a local variable that
hasn't been annotated and you'll see
that there's a conditional or so X might
take on the value of P or Q depending on
which way the conditional goes and then
we want to access X but we don't know
what to what bounds the test X against
because it might have length peel n or
might have length keulen so we're going
to do is we're going to insert a new
variable excellent and update that
variable whenever we update acts so if
we assign p2x we're going to sign peel n
2x if we assign q2 experts will assign Q
line to X and that way we can check down
here that we can check against X line so
we've we've sort of introduced some flow
sensitivity into the program buy by
introducing this new variable to track
to track any updates for its associated
pointer and once again this is a this is
a pretty general technique this doesn't
this doesn't require any knowledge about
a particular
particular dependent type as long as you
can as long as you can basically insert
new variables and copy over the data
from other variables then everything
works fine so the end result here is
that we can handle most locals
automatically and the programmer the
programmer is only responsibility is to
add these annotations on the parts of
the program on unfunctional return
values on Global's and on structures
things that are things that can be
visible across function but across
module boundaries where they'd have to
insert insert annotations anyway right
so the overall point here is that
excellent is updated when X is updated
overall yeah thanks in fact so in fact
the the only annotation that deputy
cares about is bound because Sentinel
encounter both special cases have found
so what we really do actually is we just
infer for any pointer variable where we
know that we need some bounds
information we infer a lower bound and
upper bound they get tracked
appropriately we have we have some
inference that that allows you to
eliminate one of these bounds in some
cases like if you only increment the
pointer forward then we don't have to we
don't have to interact one of these
lower lower bounds but yeah basically
the bounds the the case the bound
annotation takes card mole alright so in
general deputy handles bounded pointers
it held it handles null-terminated
bounded pointers and that's there's
actually a very interesting interaction
between ultra nation and these mounted
pointers that I'm not going to talk
about now but if you're interested ask
me later and there's tag unions as well
all of these all of these first three
things on the Left involve some form of
dependent types there are also a number
of features over on the right the
polymorphic functions allocators and
memset and mem copy which don't involve
dependent types but are very useful
anyway finally on this at the bottom
these are the things the deputy trusts
the most important of those is d
allocation and I should I should
probably add concurrency here as well
deputy assumes the program is raced free
so you're not going to have race
conditions breaking these invariants
between checks and and the data that
relies in them and also p it also
depends on the correctness of the
allocation so if you
if you if you d allocate a variable and
create a dangling pointer you can create
all sorts of messes that way deputy
assumes that you've handled at some
other way either by trusting the
programmer or by running a garbage
collector or something like that of
course we trust external library code
this is pretty standard you know you you
check locally and assume that other
people have hold there the invariants
that you're depending on and finally the
user can specify some trusted code they
can say I've checked this trust me it's
fine overall how does the compilot look
to the programmer so I've showed you
this this diagram before where we take
the code with programmer annotations we
do some inference at runtime checks do
some optimization and produce a safe
executable when the when the programmer
actually runs this they can get a
warning from the inference module that
says that they have insufficient
annotations so for example if you're if
you don't if you don't annotate a
pointer that's on a function boundary
deputy we'll just assume that it's a
pointer to a single object but if you
try to increment that point or deputy
will say something is going straight is
a little funny here you might want to
annotate that pointer with something
more interesting when you're when you're
adding runtime checks you might get a
type mismatch like if you're just you're
just assigning one pointer to another
point of a completely different type
you'll get a type mismatch there in the
optimizer you might get some
compile-time failures where the
optimizer decides that a particular
check will always fail and it'll tell
you about that before the program ever
runs and these that this is sort of the
set of things that are that are rejected
at compile time in that previous diagram
and finally of course when you run the
program you get some runtime failures
there as well all right so that's sort
of how deputy works and so let's go and
look at how we can use it within a
systems application like safe drive so
in safe drive this is a sort of expanded
version of the picture you saw earlier
where we have a bunch of drivers
plugging into the Linux kernel here
we've applied deputy to a number of
drivers and we've added these yellow
boxes are a resource tracker and a
recovery subsystem that have been placed
between the deputy the deputize drivers
and the Linux kernel now we have ads I
said before that there's a there's a
benefit in you know not adding a lot of
extra extra
stuff to the colonel I should point out
these are all these are still very small
like I'm the order of maybe a thousand
lines of code and they're very simple
it's just a keeps a list of resources
that the drivers using and can restart
the driver when necessary so you still
get the benefit of having the drivers
talk directly to the colonel without
having to modify Colonel objects or
marshal them across some interface so
the resource tracker records Colonel
data used by the driver like memory
allocated and locks acquired and the
recovery subsystem handles a failure by
releasing these resources in restarting
the driver and this this tracker in
recovery system was done by Fung's out
deputy of course is used is used to
detect failures within these drivers so
we use deputy on a bunch of Linux 2.6
drivers we use it on six different
drivers of four different categories
including network sound video and USB
each of these were ten to twenty
thousand lines of code except for one of
them I think it was about three thousand
lines we needed to modify about one to
four percent of these lines and in
general just to give you an idea of the
amount of work for somebody who's
familiar with deputy but not with Linux
drivers it's about an afternoon of work
to convert a driver so it's not a huge
burden the nice thing is that is that
once again this is all intrumental so
you don't have to sit down and convert
the entire Linux kernel you just have to
focus on a you know ten to twenty
thousand lines of code and the colonel
and and be able to annotate the the
kernel functions it uses so we had to
modify a few thousand lines of code and
inserted several hundred annotations the
far right column shows some trusted code
that's that still lies in these and
these drivers were for some reason we
couldn't use deputies deputy's
annotations to describe what the driver
was doing to test this out we injected
some bugs I'll compile time and there
are 140 tests that looked at seven
different categories of bugs and then we
ran a driver with both with and without
safe drive so the you'll see on the top
line that out of those 140 tests we had
44 crashes where the failure and the
driver caused the entire Linux kernel to
crash we had 21 failures where the test
failed for some reason but did not cause
the entire kernel to crash and then
finally over on the right here we have
these 75 passes
which are cases where there was a bug in
the driver but the bug did not manifest
itself somehow like it was on a path
that was not reached or something like
that the important feature here are the
important thing to note here is the
deputy caught all 44 of these crashes
either at compile time a runtime so in
10 cases it caught the error at compile
time in 34 caught the air at runtime in
all these cases catching this catching
this failure allowed safe drive to
correctly restart the driver in these
failure cases deputy did not catch as
many of these errors in fact 19 of them
got through in a lot of cases this is
because the the error that was
introduced was outside deputies
definition of correctness so for example
if you change a flag that's being passed
to a driver that doesn't have anything
to do with memory or type safety you
might get an error even though even
though deputy thinks it's fine finally
in this right hand column deputy
actually caught eight errors among these
75 case cases that passed these are
because there's actually a bug here
there's actually a bug it's been
introduced that might not have been hit
or might have been hit but didn't
manifest itself as a failure or a crash
and deputy has has found these and
preemptively restarted the driver in
terms of performance this is the
combined performance for both deputy's
deputies runtime checks and safe drive
itself for CPU overhead we had less than
twenty five percent in all cases and in
most cases it was more like five to ten
percent there's also some throughput
overhead and you'll notice that in
particular on this line the CPU is maxed
out for this test so all the overhead
you see is in terms of reduced
throughput instead of reduced instead of
increased CPU overhead so you can kind
of take these two graphs as being one
number the relevant comparison with
nooks is so nooks read a similar test on
the e1000 driver in Linux 2.4 we're
using 2.6 and they had about an order
order of magnitude more overhead so at
forty six percent a forty six percent on
this test on this received test versus
our four percent and 111 versus our 12
so the take-home message here is that by
using language tools we can provide
finer grain safety checks so we check
safety both within the driver as opposed
to between
driver in the colonel we provide better
performance as you saw on the last on
the last slide and it's also a
simplement implementation it's you know
about a thousand lines of
straightforward code plus the deputy
Pilar of course versus this one time
heavyweight adapter so you know overall
point is that language techniques can
provide a much better way to enforce
these safety properties yes so this
comparison entirely fear okay and in
what ways is it unfair oh can you think
of any ways well one way is that we're
comparing linux 2.6 verse 2.4 2.6 but
probably not a huge deal you could say I
mean so objections have heard in the
past are things like you know well
you're comparing the the runtime cost of
nukes is isolation layer to the runtime
cost of deputy's runtime checks which
are sort of a different thing but you
could argue that you could argue that
you know you're getting safety either
through one route or through the other
and and what matters is sort of the
end-to-end are you getting the same kind
of safety rules ok that's a that's a
good question and and no not exactly in
fact you could use the two systems
together if you wanted to the nice thing
about so the nice thing about as the
nice thing about nukes is approach is
that it is that it takes a very it's
sort of a very blunt hammer you know if
you modify anything the kernel space
then that's then that will be prevented
in deputy's case if you trust some some
portion of code and that and that code
happens and and that code happens to be
bad you could still corrupt the colonel
whereas nooks nurses approach might rule
that out on the other hand deputy gives
you these fine grained safety checks
within the driver itself whereas nooks
just says any modifications within the
driver are fine so they're they're
definitely there's a bit of a trade-off
here in terms of in terms of which form
of safety you'd like or they I'm taking
office is there might be in variance in
the
all driver interface that you cannot
express in the shirt in your language so
even though you might have no trusted
code in your in your driver itself
because something very cannot express
you cannot prove that you're maintaining
it any neck in fact that could corrupt
the colonel sort of program later when
the y-axis is some violent or something
right yeah it's definitely true that you
know there are there are higher level
protocols the drivers need to obey when
talking to the colonel and neither
deputy nor nukes tries to reason about
those there well if the corruption is
through misuse of a colonel interface
then you could still get the same the
same problem in nooks as I understand at
least lady I mean everything you're
thinking of like you know the correct
order of operations funny that the
driver writes some some location in
memory Colonel is using to from the from
the deputy perspectives just a native
Jerry memory somewhere so writing it you
check the memory safe it's fine you can
write it but in fact this integer has a
meaning which means it's maybe a bound
on some buffer that the colonel is going
to access right sure it since that's not
annotated in the deputy interface the
driver can safely write that memory
location and then when it goes back into
the colonel the colonel will actually
crash because it will crush itself shows
you put in wrong idea yeah it looks as
far as I understand when the copies this
data back you will do some checking
right on at runtime right who maintain
these invariants right on the other hand
the copying isn't the copying in nooks
isn't perfect so they you know they
could they would have to have somebody
specifically check for this you could
say you know you're you're it's it's
equally possible to write something in
nooks that checks to maintain the checks
and variance when copying back to the
colonel it's it's equally possible to
write a deputy annotation that would
that would express that that check is
wealthy is actually a dick
petition that you can actually write the
visits it's beyond your your language
very easy to do that runtime rip and
addington hugs but it's hard it's it's
not possible to write it in your in your
annotation what what we hope is that
deputies actually is flexible enough to
be able to accommodate a wide range of
these annotations I mean I'm not sure
I'd like it's certainly possible that
there be things that that nooks could
check more easily the deputy could not
but what we're actually hoping to have
for the longer term is to allow you to
extend deputy with new with new
annotations that allow you to express
new idioms that are you know maybe
specific to a particular to a particular
system so maybe you could write in a way
these idioms the the implementation of
each of these of each of these types is
it is itself not not checked or it like
it's it's trusted that you that there
are these particular checks that
maintain the invariant of each of these
of each of these dependent type
annotations so you can you can
encapsulate a lot of sort of interesting
logic within those within those
dependent type annotations and so
perhaps you could have one that that
that basically declared this this
particular invariant that you're talking
about and a lot of deputies jacket or
basically indicated you know when you
write to this integer make sure it has
this appropriate invariant putting this
check so it's it's entirely possible to
we could extend deputy to do similar
checking but I agree that there are that
there are cases like that were where you
know Noakes takes a different approach
and might have an easier time checking
these invariants it's it's also worth
noting that that the the this copying
back and forth is sort of a blessing and
a curse because in some cases in some
cases the when you're copying data back
and forth between the driver and the
colonel you're you know now your driver
and Colonel behave is slightly
differently than they did in the
original system and you might be you
might be causing as many problems as you
solve okay oh yeah so the resource
manager at safe drive that was called
one dianna x
and I right so there's a resource
tracker that's called periodically
during normal execution so when the
driver says I want to allocate some
memory it goes to the resource tracker
to say okay remember that the driver
owns this portion of memory and there's
another sub system that's invoked only
when in errors occur why wouldn't it is
a trapper to do some garbage connection
our bones presta well if if the if the
driver fries an object or releases in a
resource then the then the resource
tracker will say okay that resource is
no longer owned by the driver but then
so that so the the resource tracker
should have an up to date list of all
colonel resources the driver is using
when the when the driver goes away we
could free those for the driver if it
hasn't already but hopefully it should
have done that in its normal execution
and if an error occurs of course we'll
free all that stuff for the driver that
answer question okay
alright so finally some related and
future work first of all for see safety
there have been a number of approaches
that that tried to take existing C
programs and and make them safer there
are fat poner approaches like seeker and
cyclone that I've talked about earlier
and even earlier work called safe see
there's another approach that uses a
global splay tree that is they use a
separate data structure off to the side
that stores information about all
allocated objects previously so the Ruis
and lamb work and the Jones and Kelly
work use this technique but they had a
single giant splay tree that stored all
the information for for doing bounced
checks and this ended up having a you
know 5x to 10x slow down so it made it
impractical for for normal use more
recently in Illinois there's the design
safe code which a which uses a pool
allocation in order to separate out
these trees so you can put only a small
number is you can have separate trees
for each for each abstract location in
your program and you can store a smaller
amount of data in each tree and this
makes it much more efficient it gives it
sort of see cured like a runtime
overhead the disadvantage is that still
you need a whole program instrumentation
and control over the allocation and
finally there's there's this work on
using a shadow process you can actually
have a second processor to go along and
do the checks in parallel with the first
one though there's sort of limited
parallelism you can get there because
there are lots of data and control
dependencies in terms of dependent types
there's been a bunch of work on having
general-purpose languages that use
dependent types in order to give the
programmer a little bit more a little
bit more expressive power in the type
system so Xanadu independent ml are sort
of the the imperative and functional
versions from hong-wei seat and Frank
fitting the main difference here is that
these are so first of all these are all
aesthetically checked but also they draw
their dependencies from a completely
separate language so they they're you
when you write a dependent type you
don't talk about a dependency on some
other value in the program you talk
about
you write dependencies in some some
separate constraint language so this is
so this is it's nice if you're writing
new code but the but deputy's sort of
designed to to focus on existing code
that has dependencies between where it's
easier to express dependencies between
the data elements themselves instead of
having a separate constraint language
Cayenne is another functional language
that uses dependent types and is
undecidable they instead of having a
restricted constraint language they just
say you can write down anything but who
knows the compilot may take forever mm
there's also been a ferment of work on
hybrid type checking from Cormac
Flanagan and there's also worked by Oh
at all that had a statically typed had a
set of the type portion the program and
apparently type boxster person program
and used runtime checks in the
boundaries and finally there are lots of
other similar approaches that use
dependencies so there's great more so
it's work at on type theory which
is sort of addressing the same problem
in the context of cyclone and of course
at here at Microsoft there's been the
Sal annotation language which uses very
similar annotations on lots of existing
code like like windows in office and
there static checker SPX in fact it's
entirely possible we could use deputy
like annotations at the deputy like tool
with those annotations in order to add
some runtime checks in addition to you
using their static checking
level farther in good describe the
difference between Sal aspx I'm deputy
so they the mean the main difference
between cell and ESP X is that they're
designed primarily for static checking
so it means that if you have if you if
you have sort of the the programmer
manpower to you know change your code to
conform with the static checker and or
design aesthetic checker that is that is
powerful enough to deal with real code
that you can do then you can do pretty
well deputy allows you to occupy sort of
intermediate ground where you can where
you can check a lot of a lot of things
statically and then insert runtime
checks for the things that you couldn't
otherwise check so you can basically it
it reduces the amount of programmer time
to get their code working with this with
these new annotations in terms of the
annotation languages themselves they're
very similar annotations except that
except that sells annotations tend to be
a tend to be more like pre and post
conditions whereas deputies are more are
more like refinements of the types so
their flow insensitive and they must
hold on a given type at any point the
program instead of just at the beginning
and end of a function hmm right the main
difference is the static versus hybrid
approach to the checker yeah how do you
really a tease this out you just insert
have two checks whenever they couldn't
figure out steady I'm not sure I'm not
sure specifically whether that would be
whether that would be a challenge with
with the way ESP ex works now but my
guess is that you could use a technique
very much like deputies to insert to do
answer checks based on the salle
annotations so you could take em you
could take a lot of this existing code
that's been annotated with with sale
annotations and if it doesn't work
entirely ecstatically you could insert
some runtime checks to compensate for
that and it might make the process of
pushing style annotations into Microsoft
code a little bit easier yeah really to
this hybrid checking stuff so you
mentioned in your talk that it's
important to the optimization to reduce
redundancies between checks right so but
if you didn't do any of those and you
were just checking everything at runtime
now synaptically do you have any idea of
how what would be the performance here
and also how many of these annotation
would still be there to speak to all
media optimization get rid of right so
it would be pretty huge and the so in a
sense it's it depends on how many on how
the so there are two portions one that
inserts that one that inserts checks and
one that eliminates its checks and and
if you want to see how well the how well
the optimizer does if you want to make
it work better you can always insert
more stupid checks on the when you're
inserting checks to begin with so in
many cases the checks that we insert
it's we insert we removed tons of checks
and it would be incredibly slow without
the optimization but that's because but
that's because they're designed with
they're designed in order to do this the
it's designed such that you can insert
stupid checks to begin with and get rid
of them later okay you should impact or
toms of checks but like an order might
need you to order of magnitude a hundred
checks through one or I mean in many
cases it doesn't even compile for
example there's a there's a if you want
to do a many pointers are just are
bounded by themselves and themselves
plus one so it's a pointer to a single
object if they're an opaque pointer
where they don't have the structure
filled out in that particular in that
particular compilation unit it's illegal
to increment by 1 but we can statically
prove in all cases where you use that
that that you know you're you're never
comparing against that plus one boundary
so all the checks that involve p plus 1
get eliminated but if you try to just
compile it with those checks in it'll
say I'm sorry you can't increment this
pointer that doesn't have a note whose
type does have an own size so in many
cases you can even compile it if you did
compile it I'd imagine you to have you
know like a 10x loaded or something like
that but it's not really relevant number
because the because the whole thing has
been designed with this with this
optimization pass in mind the
optimization past leaves maybe the
number of optimizations that are left
which is probably a more relevant more
relevant measurement tends to be the
code size tends to be sort of it's
definitely within 2 X tends to be more
like you know 1.2
five or 1.5 the you end up getting maybe
one check / it's it can be as high as
one check for five lines of code as low
as maybe one check per 100 or one check
per thousand depending on what sort of
check what sort of program you're
writing so that's maybe that maybe gives
you an idea of what the optimizer is
doing how many checks we're adding
there's an approve all night for every
point of the reference right so there's
at most one check for our snacks not not
necessarily because because this this
mutation reasoning can so the way the
mutation works is it says it effectively
says check every other variable in the
in the environment and make sure that
they that they're invariants are upheld
as well so for example we had some cases
in the original implementation of deputy
where there was a giant structure that
had tons of fields if you modified one
field in there the mutation rating
reasoning would cause it to go and
recheck all fields within that structure
and it would admit lots of checks that
just said you know is p less than equal
to P is P plus 1 less than or equal to P
plus one for every field in the
structure so you'd have you know
hundreds of checks for a single
statement all of which would get
eliminated by the optimizer yeah yeah so
there's there's a simple subtyping rule
which basically says you can shrink the
bounds whenever you want so if you have
if you have a pointer bounded by P and
by base B&N e then you can cast that to
a pointer whose new base and new end are
within the old bounds but still contain
the pointer itself and that's and that's
that's actually a very important rule
because that's where all the bounds
checks are derived
that's about your date rule so the way
you said you're gonna handle this
probably keishon and having dependencies
on a despite treating the local
environment as an environment invariant
and probably not here maintaining
invariant I've every update right so did
you find the practice that is limited
the kinds of updates you could do for
example you know your structure that had
a pointer in the length right often I
might want to reallocate this array
maybe double in size maybe have excise I
have to do to updates to reestablish
this invariant right so with that you
can prevent me from doing that in some
cases yes so the question was about if
you have if you want to do multiple
updates to sort of data that depends on
one other because you're maintaining
this flow and sense of invariant it's
true that in in many cases if you if you
assign to just one field you'll get an
error because you that the the program
state is is momentarily inconsistent
there are a few ways to get around this
one way is deputies type invariant
actually allows any any bounds to be
attached to a null pointer so often what
you do is you null out a pointer change
its bounds and then assign the new
pointer and and at each step their the
program will be okay we haven't found
that to be a big burden we've so far
we've mostly just going to manually made
that change where necessary and it's it
hasn't been a huge burton has been a
huge part time if it does turn out to be
you can do a little bit you can do a
little bit better by having a parallel
assignment rule which is actually just
an extension of the of the single
assignment rule we've seen earlier that
allows you to reason about multiple
statements at once
you're not really shaking or statically
at all um well the know the null pointer
check would also be done would be could
also be kicked to to run time if
necessary saying it's not know you could
but that would prevent you from doing
this sort of this sort of dance with
nollie out a pointer I change its bad
about initialization to you you so if I
annotated field is not known can you
program check that I initializes the
let's see the checking for nominal is a
little bit limited right now so if you
annotate if you annotate something is
non-null typically it typically it's
designed for use in function arguments
where initialization isn't an issue I'm
not sure if we do the right thing for
fields
ok so that was I think the end of the
slide independent types there's also a
bunch of work on the system side so for
binary imitation there's earlier there's
SFI software fault isolation and and
just this recent OSD I x-fi which sure
takes a different approach to this
problem by looking at the binary
themselves and doing some doing some
instrumentation to the binary and then
having a verifier that can verify that
the binary is is secure for has all the
appropriate checks in it in some ways
they're in some ways it's it's an
orthogonal technique to two deputies
approach because one is looking at the
binary one is looking at the at the
source level and in fact you could you
can hopefully design a verifier that
works on deputy generated code the same
way you design a verifier for 4x if I
there's also hardware-based isolation
I've talked paramount about nooks but
there's also a Zen which uses a virtual
machine approach which is also a sort of
hardware based and that it uses the the
hardware memory protection for a lot of
its for a lot of its work and finally
there's a language base isolation so
these are cases were where we've tried
to done a new operating system with a
safe language like singularity of course
and spin and they're also there's also
work like the Java OS and less machine
all of which take the approach of you
know let's let's make a completely new
code base in a type-safe language as
opposed to taking existing code and
trying to and trying to you know
shoehorn it into a safe language all
right so in the future in general I'm
interested in developing language tools
and techniques to improve systems code
so I'd like to look at existing C code
see how programmers are writing that
code and and see how much of that we can
we can capture in a programming language
tool so deputy is an example of this
where we sort of looked at how
programmers wrote how / was wrote down
pointer bounds how they manipulated
pointers and tried to take as much of
that as we could and encode it in types
that the compiler can understand and of
course I'd like to validate this result
in real systems so an upcoming challenge
it's a little out there but
look at having a type-safe version of
Windows now lets you think that this is
totally crazy we're actually doing this
for linux right now we've got we've got
a 300,000 line linux kernel that is that
is it has all the sort of all the sort
of basic features you need from a linux
kernel it boots on a vmware virtual
machine it has you know exe to file
system and the all the appropriate
drivers for the vmware its devices we
are about two-thirds of the way through
applying deputy to this to this 300,000
line a linux kernel and should get to
the whole thing within a month or two
and at that point it's just a matter of
sort of looking at what the trusted
portions of the code are and what we
need to do in terms of adjusting the
code and adjusting the tool in order to
in order to actually process all of
licks so if we do that with linux we
should be able to do windows as well
right hopefully it can happen this is
yes so for when i talk about when i talk
with the linux work we're doing it's
still modular deallocation and and
certainly so that one of the nice things
is that you can actually reason about
them largely separately I mean there are
obviously important dependencies but you
can you can you can do all this type
safety work without having to solve the
D allocation problem and vice versa so
so yes so we could we can do this
without first reading about the
allocation but that's also of course an
interesting thing to tackle I think that
there's probably similar solutions that
you can apply to deallocation as well
where you look at you know as a
programmer I feel like I reason about
allocation very locally and and with a
relatively simple logic and that's the
sort of thing where I'd like to be able
to capture that and encode it somehow in
a language shoulder couldn't force
correct use of those rules which leads
me to the next slide which is sound
analogies analyses for large systems so
basically systems systems research has
focused a lot on finding bugs and find
using sort of heuristic tools to find
well here's a here's a list of possible
errors and here are the most likely ones
and here's a bunch of false positives
instead we like focus on something where
the metric it's more how much code did
you have to trust
how much is actually is actually checked
and guaranteed to lack bugs of a
particular kind and using the sort of
incremental and hybrid approach I think
we can make a lot of progress there the
open problems I've listed so first of
all the allocation ours is one thing
that's very amenable to this and
concurrency is another thing where we're
you know we're still sort of fumbling
around to get a handle on how to how to
reason about this in a big system like
linux or windows and this is one place
where where this incremental and hybrid
approach might help further down the
road I'm interested in looking at new
systems languages so we've we've
suffered through C for 30 years and
there should be it's still sort of the
go-to language if you're writing
something low level that has to interact
directly with hardware we should be able
to have a language that has that has
some of the that has more expressivity
empower those sorts of things you could
see in higher-level languages but
doesn't destroy the sort of the
simplicity that that people like from
the c language and hopefully by looking
at existing code and seeing what for why
programmers you see and what they're
doing in DC programs we can transition
these programs to to this new language
so overall deputy users dependent types
to enforce type and memory safety and C
programs from the pl point of view we
have a decidable sound and usable
dependent type system from the one that
works on actual real-world software from
the system point of view we have this we
have this language based technique that
gives us simple and low overhead
checking for safety properties in a in a
small portion of code that can be sort
of incrementally expanded as as the
program has time and the bottom line is
that PL tools can solve big system
problems so acknowledgments there's my
adviser George Nicola and eric brewer
was also very helpful Matt heron and
Zach Anderson did a lot of did a lot of
work on deputy itself bung sow worked on
the safe drive portion David gay Rob
annals Bill McCloskey and Elia Barack
all helped out with testing and
suggestions and so on thanks very much
Jim gonna work for c++ a good question
so I think I think a fair portion of it
could could work for c++ in fact the big
the big barrier is infrastructure
there's a lot of right now we you know
we have a nice infrastructure for taking
c program simplifying them so that you
can do this analysis and instrumentation
in c++ there are a lot of nasty corners
that make it that make it difficult to
do the same sort of the same sort of
analysis and interpretation compared to
previous tools like like secured for
example deputy is actually much more
amenable to this sort of change because
all the only changes the deputy needs to
make are inserting runtime checks as
opposed to changing the layout of data
structures which is a bit more
complicated but still it's a matter of
it's a matter of just writing
infrastructure to take C++ code and
present it to the tool in a in a useful
format but it's the the principles are
totally the same and I think it you know
I could work more or less as is so you
you don't need to extend the type system
to deal with classes and curtains I'm
you know I'm sure you need to think
about these things but I think that I
think they're they're sort of their sort
of techno technical problems that are
that are that could be overcome with a
reasonable autumn work the the biggest
problem is just it's just infrastructure
and sort of engineering
yes so your first example was a casting
a manager to an elder casting a Maggie I
rewrite and the deputies type and memory
stick right right so but a lot of C code
does dis kind of cast because they
encode subtyping or with everything
about their form right so in all your
crow that you've already run through
that you keep you running awesome yeah
and there are fair amount of cases where
we have to trust the code because we run
into cases like this the deputy can
check there are some cases like like
these sorts of up casts and down cats
that you mentioned where we're looking
at ways to capture those within deputy
itself like for example you could say
that the type of this void star depends
upon the value of this of this function
pointer that's elsewhere in the
structure but the the dependency is a
little bit less clean then than it is
for the pointer bounds case a better
solution with a little bit more
programmer work is to actually have the
programmer add a runtime type
information field associated with these
with these with these up cats and down
casts so that you can directly say this
the type of this void star depends upon
the value of this tag field and that
would be a very nice way to write this
down it's it's sort of a trade-off
between whether you want to have a you
want to sort of find some existing
dependency where it exists or whether
you want to have the program make some
changes if the program exchanges the
nice part the nice the nice thing about
that is that even though even though
you're making changes to the data
structure it's at the programmers point
of view so the programmer gets to see
the changes and make sure that they're
compatible across modules so yeah for
now a lot of those things are just
trusted by deputy yes what we do specify
the kernel interfaces
to use typically when somebody's when
somebody's applying deputy to a driver
the the inference mechanism will
indicate cases when when an annotation
is probably necessary and so the
programmer goes through and finds the
appropriate function of the colonel
headers and adds annotations so it's
sort of it's sort of incrementally as
you're as we're processing a driver will
find the colonel api's that it calls and
go in Antep a pose is that did that
answer your question was just the
originary player Oh is there generic way
of doing it is there any ideas or other
any ideas how to do so so do you mean do
you mean a way to a way to sort of
automatically generate these or specify
them in bulk yeah I understand you have
started doing this right the question
was how to do this right I mean right
now it's just manually one by one and
and the nice thing about the approach is
that because you can because you can
just process a small portion of code it
at a given time and then test it it's
actually pretty feasible to just one by
one and I take these by hand it could be
it could very well be possible to take a
to do a single whole program pass this
is to take all the code merger together
do a single pass to generate likely
annotations for some of these functions
and then use that to to give the
programmer of best guess so say this is
probably what it is but have the
programmer come and refine it necessary
so there there's certainly ways that we
could we can look at generating them a
little bit more automatically but we
haven't done that yet
other questions
right